هاي عاملين ايه
كلكم كويسين
النهارده هنتكلم عن الاكل الصحي وان هو مش
شرط خالص ان الاكل الصحي يكون اكل غالي بس
انا عايزه اسالكم سؤال مين فينا هنا بيربط
ان الاكل الصحي اكل غالي
انا شايفه
الحقيقه ان في نظريه اتعملت او بحث اتعمل
من دكتور او ماركتينجتك اسمها ريبيكا لقت
فيها ان المستهلكين عندهم زي انتويشن او
عندهم انطباع او بيشوفوا ان الاكل الصحي
غالي يعني كل ما الاكل كان صحي اكتر كل ما
الاكل ده كان اغلى
مش بس كده كمان شركات التاست فود عندها زي
ماركتينج استراتيجي ان هي تعمل اكله
مكتمله هتشبعنا فيها عيش فيها لحمه فيها
سلطه فيها درينك وفيها فاكس
بسعر نسبيا رخيص بالنسبه للاكل
اللي انا جايه اقوله النهارده ان احنا
ممكن ناكل اكل صحي عادي جدا بسعر مش غالي
ولا حاجه ومش شرط ان الاكل الصحي يكون
غالي
وعشان نقدر نعمل كده لازم نفهم حاجتين اول
حاجه لازم يكون عندنا
يعني ايه اكل يعني ايه والتاني حاجه لازم
اكون عارفه ازاي اوفر لجسمي اكل صحي
اول حاجه او الاكل مقسوم لا قنصرين بس
حاجه اسمها ماكرونز ودي النشويات
والبروتين والدهون
والتلات حاجات دول هم اللي بيدوا الجسم
الطاقه طبعا كل حاجه فيهم يا فانكشن
مختلفه وعندي حاجه اسمها الميكرو نيت
رينكس وهي الفيتامينات والمعادن
اول حاجه هنتكلم عليها النهارده هي الكورس
او النشويات مين عارف اني شويات هي مصدر
اساسي لايه
للطاقه النشويات هي مصدر اساسي للطاقه
النشويات لما بناكلها بتتحول لجلوكوز
وبتمد جسمنا للطاقه من عن طريق الكبد
والعضلات
عندنا نوعين من النشويات حاجه اسمها
كومبلكس وحاجه اسمها سيمبل كورس
هي الكورس المعقده
المعقده دي هي بطيئه الامتصاص زي ايه زي
الرز المكرونه العيش الشوفان البطاطا
والبطاطس والحمص كل ده
الكومبلكس هي نشويات زي ما قلت
بطيئه الامتصاص معناها ايه معناها ان انا
جسمي بيقعد فتره طويله قوي لغايه ما
يهدمها فبتمدني بالطاقه وتمدني بالشبع
لفتره طويله
كمان هي بتعلي الانسولين في الدم بريت او
بنسبه قليله
اللي انا عايزه اقوله على ان انا مش مفروض
او مش شرط افطر شوفان الصبح عشان ابقى
اكلت اكله هلسى انا ممكن عادي جدا افطر
اعيش بلدي وابقى اكلت اكله صحيه مش لازم
اكل سيريل او او مش عارف جالولا عشان ابقى
اكلت هلسي انا ممكن اعدي جدا اكل بطاطا او
بطاطس او رز او مكرونه او حمص وبقى اكلت
كومبلكس كورس واكل صحي
ثاني نوع عندنا هو سيمبل كورد اللي هي
السكريات زي السكروز زي الفاكهه الفكتوز
وزي اللبن ومنتجاته اللاكتوز
السكريات دي هي بتتهضم بسرعه يعني بتمدني
بالطاقه وبتمدني بالشبع الاوقات صغيره
وقصيره
طبعا هنا باين قوي وكمان هي في حاجه كمان
هي عندها قابليه اكتر لتخزين الدهون
وبتعلي السكر في الدم الانسولين في الدم
على طول بتعمل لي حاجه اسمها انس في بتعلي
الفرن في الدم عشان كده لما بناكل حلاوه
ونروح نتمرن يبقى عندنا طاقه جامده قوي
اول مجموعه بنكسرها تاني مجموعه بنكسرها
بعد كده في التمرين الطاقه تقع ان هي مش
بتمد بالطاقه لفتره طويله عكس
فواضح من كلامي ان احنا محتاجين ناكل
نشويات بس نعتمد اكثر على النشوات المعقده
او على
المفروض ناكل ما بين 45 ل 65% من احتياجنا
للسعرات في اليوم نشويات
تاني مايكرونيترونت معانا هو البروتين هو
الكينج بتاعنا بتاع اي حد عايز يعمل عضلات
هو واحد من اهم الماكرونتس بيتكون من ايه
ببساطه بتتكون من احماض امينيه عندنا
نوعين من الاحماض الامينيه احماض امينيه
غير اساسيه دي اللي جسمي بيصنعها لوحده
ومش هنتكلم عليها النهارده وعندي احماض
امينيه اساسيه الامين واسيبس هم تسعه اللي
على الشمال هنا بالاحمر التاسعه دول انا
جسمي ما بيعرفش يصنعهم محتاجه اخدهم من
الاكل موجودين فين موجودين في البوتين
الحيوان لحمه الفراخ السمك اللبن البيض بس
مع الاسف البوتين الحيوان دلوقتي بقى غالي
شويه
فمحتاجين ان احنا نفكر بطريقه مختلفه
ونبدا نبص كمان على بروتين النباتي بوتين
نباتي زي ايه زي البقوليات عندنا العدس
الفول
العدس الفول الحمص الفاصوليا كل ده بروتين
نباتي المكسرات بوتين نباتي والحبوب
الكامله بروتين نباتي البروتين النباتي مع
الاسف في مشكلتين اعتقد ان في ناس عارفاهم
اول مشكله
اول مشكله ان هو نسبه البروتين اللي فيه
اقل من البروتين وتاني مشكله ان هو مش
بروتين كامل يعني ايه يعني ما فيهوش
هيبقى في واحده مش موجوده او اثنين
الكينوا كامله اه لكن هو الوحيده اللي
جمله بس الباقي مش كامل والترمس مش كامل
همم
الحل حاجه زي كده هم حاجتين برده في
تركتين ممكن نعملهم اول تريك انا ما قلتش
ان احنا ما ناكلش بوتين حيواني احنا هناكل
فوتين حيواني وهنكمل احتياجنا من البروتين
بالبروتين النباتي دي اول فكره تاني تريك
هو ان انا اخلط البروتينات النباتيه على
بعض بحيث ان هي تعمل لي بحيث ان انا اخد
منها النايلس الامين
يعني مثلا لو اكلت شويه حمص على شويه عيش
اسمر حبوب كامله الميكسر ده الميكس ده فيه
تسع احماض لا من الاساسيه ولو اكلت عدس
وشويه رز الميكس ده في تسع احماض الامين
الاساسيه طبعا البروتين في الجرامات
البروتين فيه مش كثيره قوي بس في تسع
احماض للامين الاساسيه
اي حد فينا هنا محتاج ياكل ما بين زيرو
فصل 75 لواحد جرام بروتين لكل كيلو من
جسمه تقريبا محتاجين ناكل جرام بروتين لكل
كيلو من جسمنا والناس اللي عايز تعمل
عضلات وعايزه تعدل محتاجين ياكلوا ما بين
اتنين لتلاته جرام بروتين لكل كيلو من
جسمهم
طبعا دي مشكله في حد ممكن يقول لي طب انا
بروح بتمرن كويس بس انا مش قادر اكل 2
جرام بروتين لكل كيلو من جسمي اوقف تمرين
اعمل ايه طبعا مش هنوقف تمرين انت لو اكلت
اقل من كده مثلا اكلت الجرام بروتين لكل
كيلو من جسمك وبتتمرن اللي هيحصل هنا ان
انت هتعضل برده بس هتاخد وقت اطول عشان
توصل لهدفك ما حدش يوقف تمرين يا جماعه
هوريكم كفايه على قد ما نقدر بس ما تقفوش
تمرين ممكن النتيجه بس متاخره شويه
ثاني حاجه هنتكلم عليها هي الدهون طبعا
انواع الدهون كتير قوي هنقسمها لثلاثه
عشان يبقى الموضوع سهل اول نوع هو الانث
الدهون الغير مشبعه الدهون الصحيه وده
اللي انا هاتكلم عليه النهارده وتاني
النوع هي الساتيوريت فاكس الدهون المشبعه
ممكن ناخد منها ما بين 10 15% من من اكلها
للدهون لان هي برده فيها فوائد معينه بس
هي مش اكتر حاجه صحيه وبعدين عندنا
الترانس فانسيد الدهون الثلاثيه ودي
الدهون اللي احنا محتاجين نقطعها خالص من
الاكل بتاعنا
النهارده هتكلم عن الانثى الدهون الصحيه
طب هي زي ايه دون الصحيه ايه اكثر دهون
صحيه معروفه حد عرف
ايه
الزيتون افوكادو
سوداني مكسرات قولوا
مكسرات اوكي طيب من اكتر الدول الصحيه
اللي الناس بتتكلم عليها هو مليان اوميجا
3 الافوكادو الزيوت
والمكسرات طبعا دول اكتر حاجات
معروفه في الميديا كمان
بس اللي انا عايزه اقوله لكم هنا ان احنا
طبعا
بس هي غاليه جدا في حاجات تانيه كتير جدا
فيها امري غير سلمان يعني عندنا مثلا
التونه فيها اوميجا 3 الرنجه فيها اوميجا
3 اكتر من التونه وبنسبه كبيره
والرنجه فيها برضو اوميجا 3 الحاجه اللي
فيها اوميجا 3 الكتان زيت الحار اللي
بيحطه على الفول كل ده فيه اوميجا 3 فلو
مش قادرين سمك سلا من كل يوم محدش فينا
بيقدر يبقى فورت سمك سلن كل يوم لسمك
السلم بقى ب 1000 جنيه الكيلو تقريبا ففي
بدائل تانيه ليه كتيره جدا فيها برده
الاوميجا 3
في حاجات تانيه برضو فيها
في حاجات تانيه برضو فيها عندي حاجه مثلا
زي الزيتون حد قال لنا الزيتون ده انساك
برافو برافو عليك ههه ده انسات صحي وبناكل
كل يوم على الفطار ما فيهوش اي مشكله
فالزيتون ده صحي زيت الزيتون اكيد ساعات
صحي عندنا برضو السمسم فتصحي والطحينه
اللي بنحطها الاكل دي صحيه فيها
اللي عايزه اقوله ان احنا مش لازم نبص على
مش لازم نبص على اغلى نوع في الاكل ونقول
اه والله النوع ده غالي فانا مش هقدر اكل
صحي اللي انت عايزه من الاكله دي السواء
كان بروتين او قارب او فات موجود هو هو في
اكل ثاني ممكن يكون ارخص نسبان
بعد كده عندي حاجه تانيه صغيره جدا الجزء
الثاني من الاكل وهو المايك يعني
الفيتامينات والمعادن
كل اكله
كل اكله فيها فيتامين نسبه فيتامينات نزلت
معادن اكتر اكل مليان فيتامينات ومعادن هي
هتعرف
الفاكهه وايه تاني الخضار برافو عليك
دايما الفاكهه والخضار اكتر اكله
طبعا ما نروحش نشتري مثلا اناناس مثلا ولا
افوكادو
غاليه جدا النهارده ارخص فاكهه في السوق
هي البرتقان اليوسفندي والموز تاثير اسعار
متفوته في الحاجات دي نسبيا طبعا
كلها غليت
بس انا بتكلم نسبيا
اللي انا عايزه اقوله النهارده
ان احنا مع الاسف في افكار مغلوطه في مصر
وفي المنطقه العربيه عن الاكل ودائما
بنقيس ده تحت ابحاث من اسوسيد الاكل الصحي
بالاكل الغالي المفاجاه ان الاكل كله غالي
مش بس الاكل الصحي خلاص فاحنا محتاجين
لسنك اجانب في نفسنا نفكر في نفسنا ونفكر
في صحتنا ونفكر في صحتنا دلوقتي وصحتنا
قدام
شوف انت قادر تدفع قد ايه حط البادج بتاعك
الموضوع كله محتاج تشغيل دماغ حط البادجي
بتاعك قدامك ورقه وقلم واكتب دايت لنفسك
او خلي حد يكتب لك دايت صحي
فلوس اللي عندك لان كده كده الاكل كله
غالي
شكرا ميرسي
مبسوطه قوي اني كنت معكم النهارده شكرا
[تصفيق]